all right we are now in week 14
of the nfl season the raiders have a key
game against the colts on sunday
ron futrell joins us now with the very
latest
okay here we go only four weeks left in
the nfl's regular season it's down to
crunch time for a lot of teams
seems like a good opportunity to take a
look at the playoff picture we're going
to start with the afc
tonight the afc is kind of top heavy
you've got your two teams you've got
your chiefs and the steelers chiefs are
uh to win the super bowl are 12 to five
the steelers are seven and a half to one
and then you've got quite a gap between
that you've got the bills at 18 to one
ravens 28 and then your colts and titans
are fighting for that
top spot in their division at thirty to
one by the way the raiders are long
shots and eighty to one to win the super
bowl
now they've got a key matchup this
weekend against the colts both of these
teams
battling for that seventh and final
playoff spot in the afc
big game we opened up the colts as a two
and a half point favorite the bettors
are siding with the colts
and they're bed up now to a three point
favorite
so the raiders play their next three
games at home after the colts on sunday
they then have the chargers for a
thursday night game here at a legion
stadium
then following that the day after
christmas they take on the miami
dolphins another
afc playoff team the raiders are going
to have to contend with
at legion stadium i'm ron futrell
reporting 8 sports now